I talk about hustle here's why hustle
and busting ass the ability to hustle
one success model the best
what's up believe nation at seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn one
of the most common rules that successful
people follow hustle also if you want to
know what Gary Vee Dan Pena David
Goggins and others have to say about
building confidence and excellence check
out my 254 series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video or free to help you build
your confidence the links to join are in
the description below the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much a kid like
you if you had to keep track of seven
days a week 24 hours a day what you do
everything I didn't want to do is what
got me to where I'm at today
I talk about hustle here's why if I
looked at all of us right now and
everybody behind these cameras or
reading this article and said get
smarter more talented I want you to get
more talented that's very tricky that's
unbelievably ideological advice if I
said look two extra hours of work
actually has an impact on your success
if that's what you're trying to achieve
that's practical yeah you don't have to
but it's controllable work ethic is
controllable being born with talent is
not where I got my work ethic from was
the hours I had to spend learning this
when you sit down and you're not smart
you have a disability yeah and you still
want to be at the top of your class I
didn't want to get by when I realized
that I can learn through hard work and I
can beat the valedictorian in school if
I got put in ten hours more a day than
he does you know what kind of strength
comes from that when you're sitting down
that guy that that Valentine study for
an hour and you know I caught you I
caught you and I am dumb but I have the
work ethic to catch you that's where
David gagas got really invented yeah was
at a kitchen table with 20 spiral
notebooks that were empty and then three
months later yeah they were full and you
can go through that too I have made my
storage you're going through these power
notebooks of your life and you're like
this is how I learned this is
unbelievable
there's no miles it's not about the
models is that having a discipline every
day they say for me to learn this one
math problem it's gonna take me 10 hours
and that's where it you realize do hard
work you can do you can outwork anybody
how bad as they are but that's the part
people don't want to dive into yeah my
mom and dad work my mom worked in the
home raised four kids my dad
worked in a bank very successful
executive in a bank okay so who you
learning something from him about being
executive of dressing no I learned about
my dad real simple hustle and busting
ass so my dad was up before I was up in
the morning out of the house uh-huh my
dad would get home when it was dark I
watched my dad bust his tail watch my
dad work Saturday because he came in had
a couple cocktail all time and that was
probably the wait while I was coming
home so late for a while but in my mind
and even after he became sober he's a he
just like a lot of men of that
generation my dad just busted his damn
tail I think he lost art form with
younger guys today right
my dad just flat busted it now he busted
it cuz he was trying to provide limiting
things like food and shelter he never
thought about big things or dreams or
getting wealthy or having influence we
just wanted to survive I think the
number one thing that got me to where I
am today is just simple hard work okay
I've always worked my buns off well
beyond anybody I know in my peer group
okay but if you work twice as hard as
something you generally gonna get twice
as far for not three times father
so overwork is definitely the number one
thing I ever prepare for everything I do
born out of insecurity of maybe not
being able to deliver and what an
adventure in any situation when you walk
in and you've well over prepared over
the next competitor you'll usually leave
the situation with the gold my proceeds
from PayPal acquisition were 80 180
million ba-ba-ba-ba then I had a borrow
money for rent these guys myself
included are all in if they believe in
what they're doing they put all their
money at risk on which I have several
times not in recent years SpaceX worker
reveals a brutal company motto motto
helped him survive all-nighters working
for Elon Musk notorious workaholic Elon
Musk is so tied to his office that he's
been known to sleep on the floor I slept
on the floor
Ford slept on the poor job slept on the
floor
day slept on the floor
success leaves close you we need
I still work 50 60 hours a week and I
haven't had it work in 35 years if you
want to succeed as an entrepreneur you
need to work both hard and smart you
need both everybody who's had massive
success did both forget about trying to
work a 4-hour workweek forget about
passive income yes you can make a little
bit yes it might be supplemental income
to help you along your journey but if
you want to do something impactful you
want to have a big change in the world
you want to really be somebody special
and have a ripple effect out from you
you kind of do both you got to work
really hard look at whoever your heroes
are whether it is that you look up to
they didn't get there by having things
handed to them and they didn't get there
by trying to create passive income or
work four hours a week and I love the
4-hour work week book there's a lot of
principles you can use in there except
the fact that when you are committed to
something and you love it you got to go
all-in on it
stop being lazy lazy people don't change
the world lazy people don't have a huge
impact I want you to have a huge impact
and so hard work is just your ticket in
hard work alone is not the answer
there's lots of people who work really
hard and they never rise up they never
reach their potential right you can work
really really really hard as a cashier
but if you're not thinking on a bigger
scale and you're not working smart as
well then you'll just continue to work
really really hard as a cashier and make
whatever a cashier makes and that's
where you stay hard work does not
guarantee your success but there is no
success without hard work period it
doesn't exist
show me somebody who you really look up
to and really respect who hasn't put in
a ton of effort hard work ain't smart
work to make it happen and so I think if
you are just looking for shortcuts if
you're just looking for ways to make
that passive income or ways to work four
hours a week and then spend the rest of
timeline on the beach you're being lazy
and you haven't really tapped into the
thing that you love doing because I can
tell you you get tired of lying on the
beach you may not agree because your
life sucks right now because your work
sucks right now because you're just
trying to escape but people want to do
thing
that have meaning after you've escaped
your life and you spent a year on the
beach you're gonna get tired you're
gonna get bored you want to do something
that fills you up we want to contribute
human beings want to contribute we want
to feel like the work that we're doing
matters and we'd like to work we'd like
to feel like the activities that we're
filling up our day with means something
that somebody else so you gotta find
that and when you do you don't want to
just work four hours a week it feels you
up you want to do it a lot it doesn't
mean you're spending 200 four hours a
day doing it you got to find the balance
for you but when you find the work that
you love you want to go all-in on it you
want to keep going because it fills up
your soul so you've got to work hard and
you've got to work smart it's the only
way to succeed as an entrepreneur tell
me what influenced you to be the genius
that you are today well like in my 91
around the 90s early eighties you know
crack came out and it made a lot of
young people without bills money in
their pocket you know and they're like
you became like a young version of a man
and you know I got burned out because I
was one to have the nicest clothes and
the nicest car and you know on Linux
everyone was getting it you know and
that was normal you know it wasn't
normal to not be getting money you know
I'm saying it was like you if you wasn't
getting money he was weird
you know I'm saying he was like you know
lame so you learn the hustle yeah and in
that you know unconsciously you know
you're marketing so like if you're
putting a color on it on your drug you
know and your cat that's branding and
you'll fight because you don't want
anybody to ever compromise your brand
and pretend that they're you and they
give that work you know and then you
have to have that's when problems happen
so you fight with all you got so that
your brand and the integrity of your
brand is always maintained and there's a
lot of competition so you got to be
outside you know and once you hit the
street and you're dealing with stick-up
kids
and the police and you're dealing with
math you know the thing about like drugs
is the prices go up and down everyday
like stocks it's like that and then you
have to you know currency you have to
you spend your money as an independent
and then you put all your money in the
street you got cash flow you collect
your money it doubles then you go buy
more you might keep a little you know
and so on and so forth so once you
understand the principles of flipping
because that's what it's called and also
you're in a position where like there
aren't the police and people trying to
kill you over it you know things become
relatively easy you know what I'm saying
but um the ability to hustle and get
money that definitely happened on Linux
point number eight you will be
hospitalized for burnout or hard work
multiple times Marya knows it's watching
this from you know behind the camera is
this has happened to me multiple times
one time we're in Jacksonville and I'm
giving this talk in Jacksonville and
while I'm speaking my legs are wobbly it
looks like I'm about to pass out the
room is full it is hot it's summertime
we finish I walk out I'm walking in the
parking lot what Paul all of a sudden I
collapse
I tell Paul take me to the emergency
room we get in the RV I go to the
emergency room they set me up with IVs I
say doc what's going on with me since
you're just exhausted they gave me two
IVs I was fired up we got in to the RV
drove down to Miami stayed up to three
four five o'clock in the morning did it
again the next day why because that's
the stuff you're gonna do a few times
when you push the envelope it's just
gonna be happening I by the way some
parents will watch us and say I can't
believe you my kids are watching you
telling my kid admirers you how dare you
say this kind of stuff to my kids ma'am
sir let me simplify something for you
the chances of your kid even doing this
is less than 1% because the person was
going to do this is already thinking
about this stuff they just want some
direction I want to know when they face
off Oh God
so don't worry about your kid there's 1%
chance that your kids even gonna want to
step up to something like this the
choice you have as an underdog is if
you're gonna choose to fight and choose
to fight to win there are a series of
strategies available to you but they are
all more costly
then the strategies available to the
favorite so I give the example I have a
chapter about a and a software mogul in
Silicon Valley an Indian guy who coaches
his daughters 12 year old daughter's
basketball team and they are without
talent they are by his own by his own
admission this was like then you know
how to barely know how to play the game
he takes him all the way to that
national championships he does it by he
instructs them they're gonna play the
full-court press every minute of every
game and defend every inch of the court
right now that's actually a very
effective strategy particularly in age
class basketball if you're the underdog
it's your only chance of winning is to
play a really aggressive defense
it requires however that everyone in
your team expend maximum effort every
minute of the game you cannot loaf for
an instant you have to be in really good
shape and you have to run yourself
ragged and you cannot let up most people
will not play that way because it's too
difficult if I said to you we're not
going to be doing does this elegantly
designed plays and shooting gorgeous
baskets and passing the ball we're just
going to be doing this for the entire
game and you're gonna be exhausted at
the end most kids would say that's not
why I signed up so it's like that's a
kind of classic illustration of that
effort effort is the route one of the
routes available to the underdog
I can outwork you even if I may not be
able to outspend you but I can outwork
you well how working is a tall order
it's not easy to do you know that's as
anyone who has worked in a startup knows
that's this one of the stressful parts
of it but successful startups I am I've
never seen any actual data on this but
do we think the people working for
successful startups work longer hours
than people who work for fortune 500
companies my guess is yes after your
diving career did you have downtime
before movies yeah I mean the whole time
I was doing this
I was you know working in the streets
used to sell perfume ah yes so that was
it was a rout of the diamond and it just
kept continuing to do my only way that I
knew our own money which was on the
street corner so how would you sell
something like you'd have like like a
watch and you see a guy walking by and
would you just go sir come here because
I never stop no you don't single people
out you know it's you pull a pitch you
just talk about how you're gonna get you
know reduce things and how you're gonna
give them a bargain and how you're gonna
you know it makes sense to it's
basically you're you pulling the pieces
look there's like a stage where you you
pull the pitch basically get people's
attention you create a crowd and before
you start any of the the before you
start any of the sale technique now you
be talking about you know you what's
what I'm gonna do in a squeeze in left
leg right leg your body follows they
call it walking if you've got no money
on you now you'll be crying tears as big
as October cabbages here
left leg right leg things that will go
in for pairs will go for pennies forget
about what they cost forget about what
they worth if you with me here and now
you'll be absolutely getting a bargain
here squeezing so you just rather than
rattling away have you heard of Cartier
madam what [ __ ] will forget about what
these cost in the normal worth trade
would obviously cost you a lot of cash
yeah well map it was in these web hours
in his warehouse last night 3:00 in the
morning is squeezing and you just
rattling away with silly little things
like that and then people start to look
and listen and then you started to get
into the details of the sale you know
and then you know you take a rope chain
and then you stop to reduce it talk
about where you know how you know people
say you know you're always trying to get
people relaxed so you're always trying
to do something with a little bit of a
joke and a jess right so you're always
trying to you know make people feel at
ease
I've got a really special bonus clip
from Marie Forleo on how to increase
your productivity that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point landing questions
time to move from just watching another
video to taking action in your life or
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one where do
you need to hustle more number two what
changes will you make in your schedule
to make it happen number three who can
help hold you accountable to following
through
we're living in a time when we are
allowing our brains to be trained to
underperform we've become addicted to
check-in our phones right to social
media and all kinds of stuff and in
doing so we are reducing our ability to
stay focused and do the deep important
work that we're meant to do in this
world now what I'm about to suggest
isn't complicated and it is not
time-consuming but it will require you
to take back control of your time take
back control of this beautiful brain and
trust that your world will not
immediately fall apart if you don't
immediately respond to every ding or
every buzz or every question or every
request put your entire life on airplane
mode so don't try and ignore your phone
or ignore the emails or ignore the slack
messages or whatever else that you have
that dings and rings and pops up that's
like me telling kuma to ignore this
slice of salami ain't gonna happen
who can't ignore the salami who can't
ignore the salami
so rather than resist temptation just
eliminate it and that means you have to
put your entire life on airplane mode
now obviously turn off all the
notifications so close all the tabs
close all the windows turn off the apps
and especially for your phone I suggest
just turn in the damn thing off however
you also got a shut off some people too
and that means that you might have to
tell your kids and your spouse and your
co-workers that for the next two hours
or one hour or three hours that you
don't exist kind of like this see nobody
here if you want to learn how to wake up
early and win the day check out the
video there right next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there you got 24 hours in a
day the earlier you get up the more you
can take advantage of those hours you
actually beat the habit of hitting the
snooze